aber ich kann gar nicht mehr
weitermachen du hast die wahl
hallo mein name ist luca und meine damen
und herren ich sitze hier heute nicht
alleine wie so häufig meine videos
sondern ich habe mir ein gast geholt der
so auf einem kanal noch nie fertig sie
dass dafür die ganze zeit
[Applaus]
wir befinden uns hier meine damen und
herren ihr seht es schon in google
street view gegen google street view
was denkst du wo wir uns befinden darf
ich mich ein bisschen weiter und gucken
nur von dem worst die usa seien das ist
die usa wir befinden uns hier in google
street view und wir bekommen abwechselnd
fünf chancen und mexikos die straße zu
gehen
grundsätzlich für südamerika ist die
straße tendenziellen bis hin zu gut was
steht da 99 also kann es ja wohl nicht
nicht europa sein doch es gibt 90
aussteller gibt es 90
dafür hat jeder von uns mit fünf mal
irgendwo in google street view
reingeschmissen irgendein land irgendwo
im meer erheben mehr nicht mehr als
wertstoff street ist dass das wäre nicht
street view das wäre dann pazifikflotte
view auf jeden fall schauen wir dann wer
wie weit von seinen fünf orten entfernt
war mit seinen raten beratung beratungen
ist das raten deflation den drop proben
ja haben dann addieren wir diese werte
zusammen und wer am ende weniger
addieren gesagt ist das nicht zu
verantworten addieren kennt weil wisst
ihr was addieren ist schreibt es in die
kommunale addieren in die kommentare
hier zählen danach er die werte zusammen
wer am ende für sie weniger weit von
seinen orten entfernt hat ist entfernt
war hat diese challenge gewonnen ich
kann nicht mehr reden wir fangen an
[Applaus]
das schmecken ja wer anfängt oder das
ist echt würde auch ohne brunnen aber
ohne brunnen und ohne gewitter wie sieht
gewitter aus das ist gewiss wir sind von
mind games noch mal was denkt sowohl
befindet sich dieser ort muss ich das
jetzt sagen du musst das jetzt sagen
dass jetzt ein ort ich habe ja schon
gesagt ich glaube er befindet darf ich
ein bisschen rum klagen sind du kannst
auch soweit war ein bisschen köln bist
ok das liege dort ein bisschen länger
radar
das hilft natürlich ist es
wahrscheinlich nicht russland keinen
fall die usa auf gar keinen fall aber
ich wüsste nicht was ist das wenn also
in 200 metern kommt dünne 72 metern
kommt gut tun sie das heißt jetzt sind
wir plötzlich halte ich mich nicht mehr
also ich würde jetzt nicht mehr nicht
mehr die usa sagen wir hatten sondern
kia soul und wird
die straße wieder so gut ich würde
denken auf jeden fall auch wegen der
sprache wenn ich denn ohne sie wäre
nicht die westliche türkei weil da haben
die weniger gelten da sind die straßen
diese hübsche auf den audio classics of
majors und du bist 306 kilometer das ist
okay das war jetzt mal geht's hier um
links oder was dass das war mein geld
weil hier bin ich ja mitten im park wenn
wir das war dann gestern
ich weiß es nicht genau das heißt wir
schreiben jetzt 306 kilometer auf das
war ihr erster gast und es war aber ein
das ist also dann düst aber das war
richtig gut der entscheid des location
von ja und da sehr sehr es war zumindest
sergey brin beginnt menschen klasse das
ist nicht wahr ich halte ich ihr wisst
aber das kann alles sein
ich habe gehofft ich mich jetzt den
eiffelturm oder sondern alles bist und
vom ich fahre ich kann gar nicht mehr
weiter
du hast dich einfach bei mir was ja auch
nichts aber plötzlich dieses ja du hast
was auf der straße straßen sind
dementsprechend habe lassen was ist denn
das für eine straße 1 herstellt stehen
warum gibt es street view wollen bei uns
gibt es unseren großen städten ja wir
sind da gibt es halt im wald wo bin ich
das ist doch nicht war kommt dir das mal
an hier ist weit und breit nichts ich
finde keine zivilisation
dahinter verberge noch aber das wird
jetzt heraus weil ich ziemlich 100
karten aber wir machen das hier sitzt
seit einer viertelstunde laufen wir
diese straße entlang passiert nicht
so freuen wir laufen jetzt einer halben
stunde hier lang beschweren kann ich
mich da normalerweise eher weniger wir
werden wenigstens ein schild kommen
würde aber schau dir das an
leider habe es ist es auf jeden fall
amerika würde ich sagen okay ich gehe ja
ich gehe mal in die usa und kanada die
wälder mit den bergen ich glaube ich
gehe mal vergeben bei songs kann man
schon mal ein tipp geben also das ist
entweder ein örtliches oder südlich bei
cover ich glaube nördlich bei kanada ist
es sieht es nicht mehr so souverän aber
auch südlich mit den usa sieht es nicht
mehr so aus das heißt wovon der grenze
ist das kann natürlich beides sein
ich sage hier sind 720 setzt also gut
allerschlimmste das heißt es wer noch
weiter kanada gewesen
700 23,4 machen wir dich entscheidest
wird
das war ganz groß denn wir haben ja eine
straße
ich hab ja komm jetzt aber auch nix
dabei da kommen dagegen welche autos auf
die autokennzeichen gucken ich glaube
dass australien
das sieht sehr australisch aus ich weiß
aber nicht mal ob die frontal sind die
autos oder so fahren die in diese
richtung denn die das sehe ich nicht mal
na ja der hatten anhänger also die
werden auf einen starken linken
straßenseite er muss ja australien seien
eigentlich schon nach england sich das
nicht okay das ist das blöde australien
also schon mal auf der rechten seite ja
es ist safe australien es ist ja
irgendwo im outback oder wie das halt
fall danger season ja das ding ist aber
australien ist halb so groß die fläche
reichen pro ist einfach größer als
europa als fucking groß ist und die
einschränkungen australien hilft sehr
viel ein was wäre wenn jetzt ein schild
kommen würde sie befinden sich gerade
100 kilometer von sydney über 100
kilometer nicht so aus dass stimmen ja
toll als ob ich jetzt wisst ihr wo
mindoro ist das heißt wir wissen doch
schon mal es ist wahrscheinlich
australien ich kenne ich jetzt in
australien nicht so aus wo es eher so
wüst aussieht ich glaube aber eher in
diesem teil von australien hier ist es
eher sieht man doch auch hier ist
wahrscheinlich wieder 300 kilometer und
wir haben 953 kommen hätte schlechter
laufen können es hätte schlechter laufen
können
mit maximal aufgenommen da hatten wir
alle vierstellige kilometer zeigt das
hatten wir jetzt noch ein einziges mal
weil wir smart systems mal rein darf von
uns ist besser in unsere in denen ja
auch im leben ja in dem leben im
allgemeinen halbe leben im google sind
so bescheiden auch dass ihr habt uns
keiner und wir fanden das auch ganz toll
da ja das war schön freunde wir machen
das übrigens jetzt nur so dass jeder
drei versuche hat weil wir ein bisschen
zeit mir gerade dabei wäre gerade kanada
eine halbe stunde lang der jahren sind
weil wir gerade in kanada eine halbe
stunde gefallen sind war das ganz gut
eigentlich hat erhält eine stadt
da haben wir sogar autos aber das ist ja
das ist schade sonst kann ich darauf
gucken die schilder sehen
gesehen europäisch aus einer partie wir
sind wieder da von hier dass ich glaube
da ich will mich zu weit aus dem fenster
lehnen aber ist diese werden direkt bei
uns nehmen an ja aber das waren die die
schilder war ein bisschen anders oder
die autos herumfahren sind noch nicht so
richtig deutsche schiltach deutsche
schüler die autos sind keine deutsche
schilder also von der farbe dass hier
was blau ist und so das ist ja nicht in
allen ländern so vielen von den von ihm
ist das nicht nur bei der eu so also das
ist eu ist das habe ich mir schon
gedacht als ich bin jetzt gerade so ein
bisschen tschechien polen irgendwie da
so wahrscheinlich im ostblock ja also
ich würde sagen polen irgendwo da ich
gehe hier um die ecke pohlers partei
irgendwo hier tschechien ich gebe hier
genau genau haben deswegen majors und
wir sind vierter zwei kilometer es ist
sehr sehr gut es ist gut wenn man in der
nähe in der nähe von prad glaube
tatsächlich wir sind jetzt gerade gleich
auch wir haben du hast du 1200 jetzt
1100 kilometer das wird noch spannend
fand es gut oder schlecht das nun über
vier sterne a feeling bunga war portas
potters hört sich spanisch anja sieht
auch ein bisschen spanisch aus ja aber
kann also ich noch im regal südamerika
irgendwo da cola gibt es auch über all
das hilft mir nix ich glaube wirklich
irgendwie so argentinien wir haben da
vielleicht irgendwo in südamerika
also das ist mein onkel der holding ag
recht ich erkläre ich kann jetzt nicht
in die straße noch viel weiter gehen ich
glaube aber es ist auch noch nicht
einmal drüber 41 punkte mehr liegen
falls sie damit das ist so eine mischung
aus spanisch- und spanisch das halte ich
auch sehr groß
das kann ein ganz südamerika brasilien
bolivien da irgendwo da also alles ohne
distanzen ich kann jetzt wieder oder
köln
es ist eine letzte chance nicht gesagt
hätte köln
[Musik]
dann schreiben wir hier mal 18.500 97 96
kilometer auf es hat mir sehr
nicht so gut gefallen welche zwei oder
ein stern 1 1 hat mir das spiel kostet
das 1 ich war so richtig ob gott er ist
jetzt locker in südamerika wieder so
eine richtig große zahl so 100 kilometer
oder irgendwie so also das ist jetzt
mein letzter ort freunde da die bilder
muss ich sagen sind komplett beschissen
also von von google es sieht so aus ist
wenn die da direkt zu beginn von google
street view hin wie her gefahren weil es
echt nicht was ist das kann überall sein
es kann sein dass ich auch als 18.000
kirche auch ich fände das von
interessant wenn man mal irgendwie eine
großstadt gesetzt wird oder so aber das
passieren als lh was wir denn hier
ja die gibt es ja hier in köln ist ein
haus was sind das für ein haus wie wir
sind die gebaut dann weißt du das weißt
du was ich schaue mich gar nicht mehr
warum ich so nicht machen ich sage
einfach ich mag es auch mit
geschlossenen augen bei 21 sorgt nein
okay sie tun oder wäre perfekt und ich
habe es gemacht wie immer vor jetzt
australien wenn es gar nicht so weit weg
also soweit in relation zu mir ich habe
gesagt dass ich das mache das heißt mike
kess und es sind ja noch okay wir müssen
das gar nicht mehr ausreichend ist
eigentlich aufnahme von resource werte
waren 300 kilometer 900 kilometer und
18.500 kilometer meine werte waren es
700 405.000 dh bei mir sind irgendwo so
um die 6500 kilometer bei dir so um die
20.000 an der stelle durch das video ist
allerdings auch beenden wenn es euch
gefallen hat meine damen und herren das
gern rein leica wir haben auf dieses
kanals auch ein video gedreht indem wir
musik gemacht haben sehr lustig und die
seite
track den wir auch jesus kanal gemacht
haben weil wir nicht mehr unterschreiten
auch nicht unterschreiben also freunde
check das auf jeden fall aussehen ist
ein kanal ist in der beschreibung unten
verlinkt und jetzt kommt das outro da
ist was jetzt hier vom bio das war es
jetzt hier vom video hier können jetzt
hier mal den kanal abonnieren oder hier
unten meinen job ausschenken ihr findet
ihr zwei andere videos und wenn ihr
schon abonnent seid könnt ihr auf die
glocke klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]